why are we being sold by the media of
him being a modern day Churchill him
being a modern day you know incredible
leader who shows up wearing regular
khaki you know military clothes and
people have bought into this stuff
they're going out to want to take
pictures introduce themselves you're my
hero you're this you're that why is why
does the average person fully disagree
with you on your position because
um mostly people aren't that intelligent
80 of people have to be introduced to
themselves in the mirror and have to be
taught how to tie a shoelace
um also I think um have to be taught how
to use velcro you know that sort of
thing but also look he's an actor is
he's perfect for the job put him in a
green t-shirt always have him sitting
down because he's only five foot four
and you know that I don't agree with
short people so you don't get that sort
of perspective you go to have a photo
with him and you're like you realize you
have to kneel down this is not the good
guy this is not the savior of mankind
that is being dressed up to be